Марсель Шмідт керує вантажівками вже 30 років.
Його кошмарний сон: не помітити велосипедиста під час повороту праворуч -
там велосипедист у сліпій зоні. Марсель Шмідт знає: така ситуація може трапитися з кожним водієм.
Навіть якщо водій вантажівки не винен, бо не він, а велосипедист
поїхав на червоне світло, якщо станеться аварія,
то навіть якщо велосипедист не загине, а серйозно постраждає…
Як водій вантажівки  має дати цьому раду?
Особисто я не впевнений, чи сів би я за кермо після  такого.
На щастя, з ним такого не траплялося. Але як водій вантажівки він добре розуміє, чому такі ситуації ставалися раніше.
Раніше, коли були лише звичайні дзеркала, між цим стиком і цим дзеркалом була сліпа зона.
І при виїзді на кільце, потрібно було мало не висовуватися з кабіни,
щоб побачити перешкоду.
Тоді могло здаватися, що там нікого нема, а потім "Ой!"
За статистикою, щороку в Німеччині гинуть близько трьох десятків велосипедистів,
оскільки водії вантажних автомобілів не помічають їх при поворотах.
Але чому велосипедистів так часто не помічають? Адже водій вантажівки має дзеркала заднього виду! Але цього недостатньо.
Давайте поглянемо згори, що саме бачить водій.
Водій вантажівки бачить за допомогою дзеркала заднього виду цю ділянку
... і цю,
... але не цю.
Тут виникає так звана сліпа зона, в якій велосипедиста не видно.
Саме для цього й потрібен "асистент повороту".
За допомогою датчика він "висвітлює" невидиму ділянку.
Якщо датчик розпізнає перешкоду, то подає сигнал.
"Ассистент" повороту - це геніально. Але іноді він занадто часто пищить.
Навіть якщо нічого не
відбувається. Адже він про будь-яку перешкоду думає, що це велосипедист.
Це не те щоб дуже погано, адже щоразу, коли лунає звуковий сигнал, все одно дивишся і перевіряєш.
Коли система бачить реальну небезпеку, тоді вантажівка автоматично гальмує.
Марсель Шмідт працює в експедиційній компанії Emons. Вони використовують асистенти поворотів вже багато років.
Директор компанії обладнав цією сенсорною технологією вже 85% свого автопарку.
Оснащення системами безпеки важливі для експедиторської фірми,
щоб уникнути наслідків можливих аварій.
Ми це робимо не тому, що нас змушують,
бо ми могли б і почекати, аж поки встановлення таких систем на вантажівках стане обов’язковим.
Ми робимо це у власних інтересах для наших працівників та для нашої безпеки,
безпеки транспортних засобів та інших учасників дорожнього руху...
Відповідно до законодавства ЄС, усі нові типи вантажівок повинні бути оснащені
помічниками повороту з липня наступного року.
Вантажівкам, які часто доставляють товари до Європи, також потрібно мати найновіші системи безпеки.
Це експедиторська компанія в Україні. Кілька років томУ тут придбали
десять вантажІвок із системами допомоги водієві.
Рішення було стратегічним, адже витрати на такі системи значні.
Ця система коштує близько 1500 євро на одну автівку.
Але коли починаєш все складати, то замість ціни на машину,
яку ти купуєш умовно за 100 тис. євро, ціна може зрости до 120-140 тис. євро,
якщо набрати всіх цих опцій. Тому кожен виходить з можливостей, які в нього є.
Водії вантажних автомобілів кажуть: чим більше у фурі помічників безпеки, тим краще.
У кожній вантажівці повинен бути датчик сліпої зони,
а зміна смуги і екстрене гальмування повинні бути і в легкових авто!
Якби ці датчики були б встановлені раніше - такі як система екстреного гальмування,
то вдалося б врятувати багато людей.
Ну все! Вантажівка зламалася. Клас! Жартую, це помічник для руху у смузі.
Марселю Шмідту легше управляти вантажівкою завдяки сенсорним помічникам.
Разом з тим він знає, що в разі чого він, водій,
відповідальний за все, що станеться на дорозі.
Ви не можете повністю покластися на технології. Це приємно,
це допомогає, нема питань. Але цілковито на технології покладатися не можна.